et pour en parler nous sommes avec riadh
sidaoui directeur du centre arabe de
recherche et d'analysé politique et
sociale bonsoir yade sidaoui merci
d'être avec nous ce soir les france
comment excuser expliquez vous ces
attaques répétées elle s'était un peu
calmé ces derniers temps contre les
forces de l'ordre en tunisie répéter
c'est un peu exagéré puisque c'est le
deuxième attentat dans une année qui ont
visé les troupes dans les forces de
l'ordre mais s'inscrit dans une
conjoncture très délicate en tunisie
dans un conflit entre les deux
présidents le président de la république
highside et le président du parlement
l'islamiste rached ghannouchi qu'alcide
aujourd'hui à sousse il a dit celui qui
tente d'arranger la situation politique
en sa faveur à travers 10 à 30 appareils
il vit dans l'illusion c'est le
cinquième messages codés et
avertissements des prisons qu'alcide
contre ceux qui complotent de la tunisie
à l'intérieur à l'extérieur il dit tout
ce qu'il dit souvent je connais tous
deux connaissent tous et un jour on va
ouvrir ce dossier
donc il y a une image il ya une relation
tendue entre le président du parlement
islamistes et le président de la
république laïque qui a de pouvoir le
pouvoir de la défense et le pouvoir des
affaires étrangères qu'elle side aussi
en tant que chef suprême de forces
armées en tunisie c'est la preuve c'est
la personne la plus informés en tunisie
puisqu'elle reçoit chaque matin deux
rapports de services secrets les
rapports des services secrets de la
sécurité militaire et puis les services
secrets civile donc il connaît ce qui se
passe réellement en tunisie mais cet
attentat aussi apparemment sous tension
des terroristes amateurs ils n'ont pas
même des arbres ils ont arraché ils ont
pris les armes des deux gendarmes après
qu'ils ont opté avec leur voiture ils
ont utilisé les poteaux mais dans en
même temps dans quelques heures ils ont
été éliminés par la brigade spéciale de
la garde nationale tunisienne d'un qu'à
mon avis c'est un échec total du
terrorisme tunisienne aujourd'hui qu'ils
n'arrivent pas le maquereau blizzard a
trouvé des explosifs
leurs activités sont
les mettez pourquoi avoir choisi
précisément cette ville de sousse
station balnéaire à leur concède même à
cause de l'épidémie et toutes les
grandes villes touristiques sont
durement touchés pourquoi pourquoi
sousse en particulier selon vous souvent
ils attaquent les forces de l'ordre mais
aussi l'économie tunisienne à travers
son tourisme
certes la tacc d'aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas c'est pas pareil semblables que la
pac de kantaoui parce que les revenus
des touristes ne savons bien à cause de
corona n'y a pas des touristes en
tunisie
donc ils ont visé les forces de l'ordre
ce qu'ils appellent la route
ta route mais à mon avis c'est lié aussi
à la tension politique qui règne
aujourd'hui en tunisie entre le chef de
centre le président de la république et
le chef du parlement
donc si on vous comprend bien ce serait
l'oeuvre des partisans du président du
parlement islamistes et non plus état
islamique ou aqmi
on peut pas confirmer on peut pas
confirmer
moi je partage l'opinion de à la joue et
l'ex directeur de la dgse
je pense toujours que n'existent pas le
cas et d'un cassé en afghanistan à
kaboul en 2001 2002 la même chose pour
dash est cassée editori hardcore syrie
et mossoul en irak mais c'est toujours
un terrorisme local qui cherche la
publicité ou le panneau de publicité 2h
ou d'al qaïda
sydney terrorisme local du primitif abou
dhabi puisque n'ont pas désarmé
personnellement je peux pas je ne peux
pas dire qui est derrière il ya une
enquête
willy heineken cup deux policières et le
président de la république est bien
formé mais je peux signaler que notre
premier notre ministre de l'intérieur
note belge tous ont été un exercice au
pouvoir et l'a donné l'interview le 27
novembre 2014
un grand quotidien algérien al khabar
ils disaient qu'il y à des hommes
d'affaires des pays du golfe arabo
persique qui financent le terrorisme en
tunisie mais on a vu les premières
photos des des terroristes éliminés et
son barbu ils ont l'air aussi d'être des
terroristes deux dash
merci
beaucoup riadh sidaoui pour votre
analyse je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur du centre arabe de recherche
et d'analysé politique et sociale